foreign
let's go to will in St Louis what up
Will how we doing man
good uh thanks for having me of course
dude what's happening
uh not too much um
thanks for having me and uh just um I've
been listening to you ever since you
took your first call on the Ramsey Show
for real yeah dude right around me for a
while and uh yeah I I've listened to
every episode of your podcast and uh
dude I really enjoyed that man thank you
so much my mom doesn't even listen to
that many man you're like in the Sons of
Anarchy gang dude I appreciate that so
what's up man
um so my question today is how do I
balance the need to provide financially
for my family along with the need to be
present for them
um background is I uh am married uh
married for 12 years I have three kids
who will be six four and two over the
next few months
I grew up in a very financially unstable
household
we were a blended family I am one of
seven siblings my dad was a
self-employed mechanic for most of my
childhood and was a sole income provider
for my family my stepmom stayed home to
take care of the family
my uh dad never made much money
um it was never talked about directly
with us but the signs were there now
that I'm older and I think about it um
and I know that my uh like I know my
parents filed bankruptcy at least twice
maybe two
um before I was a teenager
I never went without foods but uh now
that I'm older and I looked back and I
and I I think about what we ate and
everything it was because it was very
cheap meals um hail real quick real
quick
I want I want to make sure you know this
is is not a math problem and what I mean
by that is this it's very easy to look
back and say we had money problems as a
kid and so now I'm gonna struggle with
when is enough how much money do I make
all those but those are math problems
questions
I need you to know in a home with a
bankruptcy
that's like living in the middle of a
hurricane
and so money has made its way into your
soul as the reason why dad's always
angry my mom won't talk to me what
brother and sister are always fighting
like you see what I'm saying so it it
became it it grows tentacles into all
these different aspects in your life
does that make sense
yeah um I kind of don't need to finish
the rest of my style
sorry so um I I can't when somebody says
bankruptcy like it that is it's like
dropping a bomb in somebody's home
and doing it two and three times the
shame the failure the I'm not the dad I
could have been and most dads of that
generation didn't have the word didn't
have the skills to say hey guys
um I my my business fell through what
they had the skills to do was to sit
down on the recliner and yell and scream
it or be silent right and then moms like
my husband's a loser and I gotta deal
with this and I'm stuck with these kids
all of that energy gets transferred into
kids
and they're left wondering what did I do
to screw this house up
yeah
I was never I don't remember
him go to work work all day come home at
like eight or nine eat dinner and then
fall asleep on the couch like we never
did anything because she was always
working and when he was home he was
sleeping right so
um but uh and you know you know that
that okay we talked about your old man
all day I won't talk about you okay so
tell me where you are right now
so um
so I learned from a very young age that
I needed to work to basically provide
for myself
um I mean I was 12 years old and I was
mowing lawns delivering papers same here
same here same here I was making close
to 600 bucks a month as a 12 year old
um
just hustling fast forward to now
um I got married at 20 to my high school
sweetheart um she came from an upper
middle class is she awesome
yes yes
um she came from an upper middle class
family and I thought it was my
responsibility to provide for her on
this uh so she had the same lifestyle
growing up
um
um and then uh we did that the wrong way
got it got into a lot of debt
um and um fast forward uh for the first
10 years of our marriage last couple
we've been working on getting out of it
but um when my oldest was born uh that
year I was on track to make about 28 to
30 000 and I took a job that jumped it
up to 70.
but that also came with a lot of work
and a lot of travel uh this year
um I'm on track to make 130 okay
um
but I have this need in my head that
it's not enough and I I'm I I want to
call it a pathological need to make sure
that we don't go backwards and my kids
don't experience uh the childhood
that I did and uh
I can't
get emotional
um I can't figure out when to stop and
yeah dude
um so I I'm holding this up here like I
wrote down all my notes you while you
were talking
you need a metric for enough when is it
that's the note I wrote myself okay so
you're already there
um let me tell you what happened in my
house okay because you and I have a very
similar story my dad never declared
bankruptcy but he was a policeman and
then he switched over to become a
minister and so uh we were hounded by
money my whole life okay this idea um
and I like you I was working since I was
11 or 12 mowing lawns
um and working maintenance at the local
church and I was always just doing odd
jobs all over the place
um this year so I I spent the last 20
years of my life working in education in
some shape form or fashion whether
University or a public schools or
whatever
and the last couple of years when I took
this job with Ramsey Solutions it's the
first time I've ever had the opportunity
to the more you work the more we'll pay
you
like the more you create things and help
other people that bring Revenue in the
more you can make
and I felt like uh dragons Unleashed in
me
and it was this past you may have heard
me say this I may have talked about this
on this show
it was not this Christmas but the last
one I went downstairs I was sick I was
trying to get my workout in and my wife
came down and she's like what are you
doing
and I was like well I gotta get I gotta
work out because then I gotta go do this
and then I got
and she said something that was um kind
of a shape shifter for me and I've spent
the last year trying to figure out how
to live out of what she said okay here's
what she said
she said
if my life is a pie chart your good
looks that that
part of the pie chart is full
any pathological psychotic workouts that
you need to do above that is because of
your ego not because of me
and I always thought I need to be in
great shape for my wife that was like a
that was a story I carried with myself
she won't love me if right and then she
said and while we're here
you've written two books you've done
this you've done this you've done this
we've made more money in the past
however many months than our families
could have ever wrapped their head
around
and you won't stop and then she said
this the we need more money bucket is
completely full anything beyond this is
about you and your ego and what you
think you need do not blame us and dude
that shook me to my core
because I was doing all I was doing all
this hustling and running and running
hustling
under the guise of I'm providing for my
family and I never want my kids to
experience what I experienced right same
as you is that fair yeah yeah absolutely
here is here is the
I want a short circuit a year of your
life for you so that I can tell you
where I've landed right now and I want
you to know like I've met with wise
people I've gone to visit people I've
read books my wife and I have had
Retreats I've done all the stuff right
ultimately
you and your wife have to sit down and
do the hard work and it's harder than
just going to get it getting another job
or another job another job
it's asking yourselves what life do we
want to create for our family
and it that is what kind of house do we
want to have as a dream what kind of
house would be great it would be fun
how do we want to feel every day
like what kind of energy do we want in
our home do you want an electric energy
do you want a warm and peaceful energy
what what are we going for here
and then the hard work for a guy like
you and for a guy like me is we have to
then say okay
I've got to stop working so much because
that's cutting into what we both decide
we want for our lives does that make
sense
yes yeah and then the other magic is
uh and Dave Ramsey's helped me a lot
with this is keeping in mind the ratios
because if you're not careful your life
will just continue to expand with the
more money you make
you get what I'm saying
um and so can you get a raise and keep
your lifestyle the same I can't I
actually have to intentionally step My
Lifestyle down a notch I've got to go
backwards a little bit
um and so every time we have a success
I'm gonna actually buy fewer things that
next month and it just helps me to keep
myself honest that's just the way I've
learned to manage it but can we keep our
life this can we stay a camera Corolla
family through the next raise and the
race after that and the race after that
so we can build actual wealth you see
what I'm saying
yeah all of this circles around that
word that is we do not have a psychology
for in our culture and that's enough
everything is built on growth getting
bigger getting more can you expand why
aren't you are you gonna buy a business
do you have a rent house yet we do not
have a word in our culture for enough
because that word feels like failure
right
yeah it does yeah so let me ask you do
you have an emergency fund
no um we're still paying off debt I'm
down to about thirty thousand dollars
left out of a hundred and twenty that's
incredible dude dude just for a second
applaud yourself man
apologize that's incredible now I will
tell you this is my personal opinion if
you owe somebody money
your ba actually I think it's science
your body won't let use rest because it
knows
it knows you're not safe it knows that
just it takes one layoff one car wreck
one something and you were right back
where you were when you were 12.
I believe that with all my heart that
you cannot be fully without anxiety
until you owe nobody any money so what
I'll tell you is keep your foot jammed
into the floor until you get that money
paid off and I'm going to tell you to
keep that sucker running until you have
an emergency fund because I've been with
you where you are and until I've got
some money that I feel safe I can sit on
for a minute
then I keep feeling like I gotta grind I
gotta grind gotta grind gotta grind
so you're on the right path my brother
you're right there you're right there
but I love you and your wife to begin to
have the what do we want this thing to
look and feel like and how do we build
that world because it might be that you
go back to making seventy thousand
dollars or a hundred thousand dollars
when you owe nobody anything and you
have a full emergency fund you can kind
of do what you want
how does that sound does that sound
crazy
it does because I I don't know if I can
I don't know how to switch that part of
my brain off like you gotta hey you
gotta it's not a switch it's not a
switch stop thinking of it that way it's
not on or off
and it's not like a a puzzle piece
you're trying to find this is training
your body because your body loves you
dude and is trying to take care of you
and it remembers having nothing it
remembers the fights and The Angst and
dad that was never home and if I I don't
wanna I don't wanna talk trash about
your old man but he was it was an addict
he was addicted to work he was actually
addicted to being busy
because he spun his wheels really really
hard he just never went anywhere
right and that tells me he worked he was
a really hard worker and also did not
listen to wisdom it was a really hard
worker and didn't have anybody in his
corner with him that was like what are
you doing why are you doing it like that
why don't you do this because that's a
guy that you point in the right
direction with some grip on the tires
and he's going to go really far really
fast
see what I'm saying
yeah yeah and yeah so your body knows
all that and it's just trying to keep
you safe man and so what you have to do
it's not a matter of finding a switch
it's a matter of slowly over time
teaching your body yeah that was not
safe
and I've got forty thousand dollars in
the bank I don't owe anybody anything
we're good
and if the air conditioner goes out the
biggest fight my wife and I are going to
have is who's going to call the the
repair person
not can we eat this month and when your
body takes off on you you're gonna
practice feeling it and going oh man
there it goes yep I do I owe thirty
thousand dollars in credit cards or
student loans or whatever I I borrowed
I'm gonna get that knocked out
and then you're gonna go about getting
it knocked out
I will also say this my brother I think
that the word balance is a myth I don't
think it's real I don't think it exists
I have found great success in my life
living by Seasons there's just Seasons
when I got to wear a coat because it's
freezing there's just Seasons when uh
sun's out guns out I don't wear
sleeveless shirts just because that
would look like an idiot but you know
what I'm saying like there's just
different clothes that you wear for
different seasons and so there you're in
a season right now where your body is
screaming at you we're not safe we owe
people money awesome listen to it run
get that stuff paid off as fast as you
can your kids are going to be okay if
you sacrifice one more year of grinding
it out so they can have
the rest of their lives with parents who
are stress-free when it comes to money
now you're talking
and if you were able to get around town
in a used Camry or used a cord or a used
pickup when you were making 28 in 30 000
you get around town with the same truck
when you're making 130 000 when you're
trying to meet other goals you don't
have to move up to another car you don't
have to move up to Phil whatever
whatever whatever
my dirty little secret is when I was
making thirty three thousand dollars a
year I had a 2001 truck
and now that I'm making way more than
thirty thousand dollars I have a 2006
truck and I'll buy something new at some
point but right now I'm that's just
getting me to work it back and I'm fine
and so I'm not letting my lifestyle get
grow concurrently with the money I'm
making because I want to change my
family tree I want to change my legacy
and all that started with a conversation
my wife had with me and said we have
enough
stop running I want my husband back
and that's a hard hard lesson my friend
it's not a switch something that you
practice hang on the line I'm gonna send
you a copy of one your past change your
future I want you and your wife to read
that together and I'm also going to send
you all the questions for humans cards
for the kids and I want you to practice
not being a dad who works so hard he
just collapses everything gets up and
goes and gives and goes again and goes
again one should be a dad who practices
talking to his kids at breakfast and
surprising them on Saturdays and
engaging with them for breakfast or for
dinner or whatever and learning how to
have conversations with them so you
learn to love being in their presence
and they love learning to be in yours
cool thank you so much my brother